Since passwords have problems and
we said that's only one of the ways
in which you can do authentication,
let's look at some of the other ways
in which authentication can be done.
So the second one was
something you have.
So a token or a smart card or
something like that,
obviously if it some thing you have,
then you must have it on them.
If you don't have your token or your
smart card or your smartphone, if that's
been used as the something you have,
you can't obviously access the system.
And people sometimes
forget these things and
don't have them on them when they
need to access especially banks,
when they give you these tokens or send
you some sort of a code through them.
If you don't have that with you,
you're not going to be able
to access your account.
So, not having them
would cause a problem.
So you do have to have them that that's
one of the requirements when you
use this method.
So obviously,
if it's something that you must have, it
should be able to talk to the system, or
the human has to enter the PIN or
whatever code that is sent to them.
But if it's a smart card, the smart
card has to talk to the system,
which requires you have to
have a reader, for example.
You should be able to
swipe the smart card and
it should be able to communicate.
So that adds the hardware
requirement which increases cost.
Even if you have it at the other
end they should have a reader.
If they don't have it then you
can't use it with that system.
How is authentication implemented
with something you have?
If you have a smart card
we were just talking about,
then it can talk to the system,
then there could be some sort of
challenge/response kind of a thing.
So the system can say, if you really
belong to the user that is being
claimed, or claim is being made about
the identity of a certain user then
that user's smart card
has a certain secret.
Use that secret to sort of maybe
respond to my challenge, encrypt it or
something like that, or
do something to this challenge.
And the response should demonstrate
that the secret that is stored
in this smart card is the one that
is used to generate the response.
So, sometimes, if you have some
processing this smart card.
Smart card can do this
sort of computation,
generate a response that could be sent.
So this PIN and chip kind of cards,
the chip can do this kind of work, and
that's how this would we implemented.
The problem with this is that
there is added cost, and
of course sometimes there could be
misplaced trust in this kind of
tokens or cards that we're talking
about for something you have.
There's of course the very well
known case of the RSA breach,
where the master key was compromised.
And as a result of that,
all the SecureID tokens that RSA
stronger authentication relied on,
you couldn't count on doing correct
authentication using those.
So there's added cost we are talking
about but there's also vulnerabilities
or attacks that can limit
the strength that authentication,
the stronger authentication that
these kind of tokens provide.
So, something you have,
you don't need to remember those complex
passwords we're talking about, but
we need to be aware of the fact, and
that they have their
own set of problems.